en quelques semaines les outils change
de statut auprès de washington dans les
derniers jours de son mandat
donald trump décide de les placer sur la
liste noire des groupes terroristes
mais dès son arrivée à la maison blanche
joe biden annonce un réexamen urgente
cette décision le secrétaire d'état des
états unis a confirmé il ya quelques
jours la décision de la nouvelle
administration qui entre en vigueur ce
mardi
nous avons entendu les mises en garde
des nations unies des groupes
humanitaires et des membres des deux
partis politiques représentés au congrès
parmi d'autres selon lesquelles ce
classement aurait pu avoir un impact
dévastateur sur l'accès des yéménites
aux biens de première nécessité comme la
nourriture ou le carburant
aujourd'hui de nombreux groupes
humanitaires travaillent dans les zones
contrôlées par les outils son revirement
de washington leur permet de ne plus
être considérés comme complices et donc
d'éviter d'être poursuivis par la
justice des états unis
une décision qui devient officiel
quelques jours après l annonce de la fin
du soutien américain à la coalition
saoudienne contre les outils au yémen à
des rebelles et qui continuent en ce
moment même leur offensive pour
contrôler le nord du pays